hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on foreigner again and yes we
finally have an answer to the all black
color swatch that people have been
asking me to talk about within these
videos for the past like two or three
weeks I knew there wasn't going to be an
answer until today so I wanted to hold
off on it but we finally have an answer
for that we have an answer for the steel
changes coming because the steel super
low this will some Raider nerf a
possible hito carry nerf glide buffs all
that type of stuff so it was like life
we'd like to be if you do enjoy guys
subscribe if you're new I covered the
informational site or foreigner that
being balanced changes here update spent
roads and leaks if you want to be kept
up to date with everything happening
within the wall before owner and never
miss out an update that will make sure
to subscribe to the channel and with
that my Twitter and discord reading the
description down below and let's get
started with today's video so first up I
want to get the content of the week out
of the way really quickly and pretty
simple this time around it's going to be
the apollyon mask from seasons ago
except it's going to be for the woollen
everyone else in the game has already
had this including new characters like
BP and Sakura but the woman never
actually had this so they are now
receiving the same dream which is pretty
nice it's a pretty solid mask I've
always liked this mask personally Anna
fits well on a lot of certain characters
depending on what their helmet and what
ornament they have going on and stuff
like that so for characters like
gladiator could fit really well but some
people like PK can also fit really well
but some other characters that kind of
clips through their head so that's not
really my personal taste so let me know
what you guys think of it for the Wulin
and what character it kind of fits with
I think it definitely fits a lot with T
on D but not really so much a Shaolin or
new show but that's just me of course
besides that we have your standard new
arcade quest which you can get the new
arcade effect if you want to and perform
the most takedowns in the realistic
Dominion game mode there's also going to
be a sail on more darker toned items and
effects so grab that while you can if
you're looking for that more edgy look
on your character and then they also
happen to cover a Q&A session which was
a majority of the scene and to summarize
that as always if you saw a recent
ubisoft post there tweaking the dynamic
rewards and raising the steel and
increasing it as opposed to what it was
now now it's like 6 steel I've seen
people get or like 30 steel for a
Dominion game so they're gonna be
changing that hopefully getting it to a
pretty balanced section the reason they
did the dynamic rewards is because
Dominion would give lots more steel than
a duel and a lot of people that play
Dule and specifically duel weren't
getting enough XP weren't getting enough
steel because they were playing those
game modes and they're being punished
and receiving less for playing a game
mode that they like so they wanted to
balance everything out so it doesn't
matter what game mode you play as long
as you play a game mode but the problem
is that there was a lot less steel than
a lot of people were anticipating
getting so they're gonna be trying to
tweaking that a little bit and I believe
that's what the hotfix was so we should
go into the game now let me know what
the steel is in-game for you guys
and hopefully it'll be a balanced number
next on the Q&A session expect to see a
lot more uninterruptible lights from
characters in the future characters like
la bearing I do now believe have
uninterruptible lights the term
uninterruptible means so within for
honor if you throw a heavy attack and it
gets blocked you can continue to chain
but if you throw a light attack and it
gets blocked then it stops the chain
uninterruptible lights follow the same
as regular heavies so if your
uninterruptible light gets blocked you
can still continue in your chain so that
is what that means and some characters
within the game currently have that
especially new characters when they just
got their reworks so expect a few more
characters to get that in the future not
a lot of not every single character is
gonna be getting it because then that's
just gonna be a complete blocking fest
then that doesn't really fit well
because then you won't even have it a
chance to attack because you're just
gonna keep getting hit with light
attacks constantly and it's just not
gonna be a fun time next up and this is
the raider nerf i do believe but raiders
dodge gb may be removed at some time
this is of course will be seen as a nerf
but as of right now his dodges gb is
still going to be in the game but the
devs have been slowly leaning on
removing it soon so hopefully that gets
dealt with soon a lot of people have
been complaining about the dodge gb
because if now his strength of the
stunning tap and the strength of the
dodge gb it's just a whole lot of stuff
to make the character super good so
hopefully that does get removed because
the stunning tap is pretty solid as it
is right now they also do have a
midseason patch coming and that's going
to be covering a lot of things I'm going
to be mentioning very soon but one of
them has to do with stamina if you're
out of stamina and you get hit by a move
that would usually make you lose stamina
now it's just not going to remove it
it's going to halt it so you're not
going to be stuck at zero stamina
forever so characters like Conqueror
Valkyrie Centurion characters like that
that are going to keep bashing you and
kicking you they're not going to drain
your stamina all the way to zero and
keep it at zero it's going to slowly go
and if you get hit it's gonna stop it
may be like let's say 20% and then it's
gonna slowly go back up again and then
if you get hit it's gonna stop and
they're just going to keep stopping and
going until you're back to stamina as to
make the fight a little bit better on
your side because it's a real big pain
when you constantly keep getting swiped
and kicked and all that and it's just a
real big pain in the ass so it's
definitely a really good play by then
also a lot of people I've even seen in
my comment section we're complaining
about the little to no wobbling or hyper
armor and this is because the character
is a counter attacker he has light
attack top-heavy unblockable impale and
zone and some of those moves can
actually start chains for the lava
ringer which is a lot compared to most
characters in the game so having high
problem would really fit his play style
and can call someone balanced within his
character so that's one of the main
reasons that they don't have the hyper
armor because as I stated he's a counter
attacker which really doesn't fit well
with the game being all trying they're
trying to push a motive of being a lot
more aggressive yet he's the only
character that really has to be
defensive and then attack so I'm not
really sure why they did this but they
had to of course have to make some type
of counter attack character and he just
happens to be that one I've also heard a
lot of people talk of my discard saying
the hito carries force beat is too
strong and overpowered and I completely
get that it's like a 200 damage move and
it's intended to one-shot you and it's
also intended to be strong one of the
problems is that it can easily lower the
commander's health especially if you're
running a 2 stack or a 3 stack of heat
so Kurian in breach game mode but the
devs don't really see this as a problem
because of course it is very early in
the season and a lot of people want to
play heat so kiri because as you can
tell now not many people apply black
prior anymore so give it a couple weeks
to maybe a month a lot less sakura's and
heat oak areas will pop up and that
really won't be as a big of a problem it
breach anymore and the commander won't
die in like 3 hits regarding that
midseason patch as well there is going
to be some plans to pick the side d flex
during that patch as you may know site D
flex are a lot harder to lend than top d
flex because of the window of time you
have to deflect
so they're gonna be changing that a
little bit making it a lot easier to
land those because I think that'd be a
lot better for the assassins I've
characters and help them you know gain a
lot more advantage within the fight in
my favorite part about this entire Q&A
is that of course it is confirmed that
gladiators guard will be a lot better
more likes of the other assassins in
shinobi the problem is that we already
knew this and in terms of a release
they still haven't said which is very
sad I've been patiently waiting and it's
probably not going to come out until
like the midseason patch or probably
next season by the looks of it which
really sucks on top of that revenge is
also going to be tweaked once again it
there is a slight bug which you may or
may not have noticed when you're in a
one on two one on three one on four type
scenario and even though they're all
hitting you at once your revenge bar
doesn't really go up any higher than it
would if you were in a one on one so
it's really hard to tweak but they're
throwing out some ideas to help fix that
because it's a real big pain in the ass
and that can really affect most of the
match and kind of make even lose the
match sometimes and then lastly in terms
of upcoming defensive move to the devs
are looking into changing some of the
moves such as no BOCES hidden stance JJC
foo pose and the shinobi backflip the
reason is that all of these allow
players to either get more space and run
away from the fight such as the backflip
or dodge a lot of moves and be able to
attack very quickly because of the low
recovery like hidden stance and Sifu
pose making fights against these
characters semi challenging even having
to be able to stack in a two-on-one
against these characters especially JJ
because of his high damage so gonna be
trying to tweak a little bit of these it
sadly looks like this might be a no
bushi nerf because of her hidden stance
but I hope it isn't because the bush it
really hasn't seen much treatment and a
lot of people think she does need a buff
because if she's kind of that middle to
your character nothing too crazy but
nothing too high damaging either and you
kind of have to play a little bit of
mind games with your character against
the opponent as well to even win but
still I hope it's not really a huge nerf
but it does like it might be a nerve for
her later in the upcoming patches most
likely the midseason patch or maybe next
season or something like that and yeah
just to end the video one quick note for
the thousands of you that are probably
eager to understand this question there
has been a thing that has been shown and
I believe the color swatches of the game
and an all-black apollyon color for some
odd reason that's in the game and it's
just to play the realistic game modes
here is your answer all you have to do
is play the new event game mode
realistic Dominion which is currently
going on now there is no date on to when
this is going to be gone I would assume
in like a week or so or maybe even the
weekend so get it as quick as you can
I'm pretty sure all you have to do is
play and then you're just going to get
the color and might be a chance of a
random drop or might be guaranteed for
the character
what all you have to do is play the new
game-mode realistic Dominion which is in
the event tab playlist which is next to
the statue on the faction more it'll be
right there next to your breech Dominion
do a duel type game modes just play that
and you'll get your all black color
which I'm very excited for a lot of
people of you asked me this question and
I didn't have an answer because I knew
it had probably had something to do with
this so there's your answer to that yeah
I'd like to be if you do enjoy guys
subscribe if you're new I covered the
informational side a foreigner that
being balanced changes hero updates
Patchett's and leaks if you want to be
kept up to date with everything
happening within the wall before
definitely stay subscribe to the channel
you guys for watching the video I do
appreciate it let me know you guys
thoughts on the Q&A stuff in the
comments below also another that season
10 has been going on for a couple weeks
let me know your thoughts on Raider a
lot of people have been saying he's
overpowered recently but I think that if
given enough time I feel like we can
learn the stunning tap I'm getting to
learn it a little bit the more I play
but I do have to admit it is still a
very strong move in his arsenal and I
think that's okay because that's really
the point of a rework yeah like I said
like subscribe all that stuff my two
most recent videos are gonna be popping
up on screen at the end of this video if
you guys want to check those out highly
to appreciate it we got the roadmap to
talk about in the season 9 state of
balance and kind of where the characters
are gonna be going heading into the
newer seasons sort of patches and you
know nerfs and buffs yeah watch those if
you guys want to and with that peace out
guys everywhere yesterday and enjoy
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]